my name is Richard pill from the private
equity firm ap capital partners in the
u.s. in the United States I am answering
question number one what is the biggest
resource untapped resource in Latin
America and along the lines of a
professor classroom has been saying I do
believe it's the people of Latin America
and emerging workforce that is there
that could be being a lot more syllabus
and a lot more skills-based labor to
help the economies of Latin America I
think everybody knows about the natural
resources that not in America do you
think there's a further exploration
there but I do on the pitch as the
biggest potential I think that is a huge
potential as well but the people of
Latin America I think representing a
multilingual skin workforce to be a lot
to have the future of this regional
superpower you know become more dominant
in a global economic landscape